take your word for it and to some degree
I believe it look I I think that in
hosting a show uncensored and I can't
see you but I know you put up the very
festive uh holly leaf on the on the
globe there um it is incumbent upon you
you will say I believe in the concept of
free speech now I will I'll be very
clear in my definition of free speech
it's the Constitutional definition of
freedom of speech all speech is
permissible outside of a crime and we
have very clear parameters and these
have been affirmed by the Supreme Court
as to what that is that's a proac Ive
call for violence the crime is not the
speech the crime is the action causing
violence on purpose outside of that
everything is permissible